When he was in his 20s-- it was years ago-- Pablo Torre started appearing on TV, talking about sports, talking about something that now he's kind of embarrassed about.
帕布罗·托雷在20多岁时——那是几年前的事了——开始出现在电视上谈论体育，谈论一些现在回想起来让他有点尴尬的事情。
I was a gasbag on ESPN. Various people did not like me, I think. I just sort of represented this new young person who was vaguely Asian but also Mexican. I'm Filipino. That answers that mystery.
我在ESPN时就是个吹牛皮的。我想，很多人不喜欢我。我只是代表了这种模糊地带有亚裔背景、但也是墨西哥裔的新一代年轻人。我是菲律宾裔，这解开了那个谜团。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
But I had this take from the very beginning of my time on TV back in 2012, which was, we debate in sports all of the time. How much did the refs blow this? What should the call have been? Who's the hero? Who's the villain? What's right, and what's wrong? And I had been arguing forever that robots can solve this. Like, we have the technology. If you replace the referee or the umpire with a robot, we don't need to waste our time arguing about this dumb shit.
但我从2012年刚上电视时就有一个观点，那就是我们一直在体育界争论不休。裁判漏判了多少？判罚本该是什么样的？谁是英雄？谁是恶棍？什么是对，什么是错？我一直争辩说机器人可以解决这个问题。我们有这种技术。如果你用机器人取代裁判，我们就不用浪费时间争论这些蠢事了。
And so that became your stance.
于是这就成了你的立场。
It became a thing I was known for, was calling for this robot referee revolution. Like, the guy won't shut up about these robots.
这成了我的标志，就是呼吁这场机器人裁判革命。就像是，这家伙一直在唠叨这些机器人。
He winces now when he thinks about it.
他现在想起这件事时会退缩。
Anyhow, years go on. And then finally, in 2021, I see this story break that, at long last, the most traditional sport in all of America, Major League Baseball, is experimenting with robot umpires in the minor leagues.
总之，时光流逝。终于在2021年，我看到了这条新闻：美国最传统的运动——美国职业棒球大联盟——终于在小联盟里试验机器人裁判了。
Minor league teams installed what they called the ABS system, the Automated Ball Strike system, these hawkeye cameras with optical tracking. They looked out over home plate and saw perfectly whether every pitch was in the strike zone and then told the human umpire, who was standing there, through an earpiece, whether to call it a ball or strike.
小联盟球队安装了所谓的ABS系统，即自动好球带系统，这些配备光学追踪的“鹰眼”摄像头。它们俯瞰本垒板，精准地判断每一球是否在好球带内，然后通过耳机告诉站在那里的真人裁判，是判好球还是坏球。
And the way it worked in the early versions is that the robots made the call, and the human umpire just let the fans and players know what the robot said. Pablo got what he always dreamed of, what he'd always pontificated about. There was no more need to argue about the umpire's calls, no more reason to boo the umpire from the stands. And? When Pablo watched those games?
早期版本的工作方式是，由机器人做出判罚，真人裁判只是把机器人的决定传达给球迷和球员。帕布罗得到了他梦寐以求的，他一直大谈特谈的东西。再也不需要争论裁判的判罚了，也不再有理由在看台上对着裁判喝倒彩。那么？当帕布罗观看这些比赛时感觉如何？
It wasn't as good. It wasn't as good. Because so much of what going to a baseball game is like is you sitting in the stands and effectively using the airspace around you as this sort of pillow you can scream into, releasing whatever it is pent up over the course of your day and your week and, frankly, your childhood. And you're getting to unleash it on-- and this is, I think, a really important part of this-- on another person.
效果并不好。真的不好。因为去现场看棒球比赛的很大一部分乐趣，是你坐在看台上，有效地将周围的空间当作一个你可以对着它尖叫的枕头，发泄你在一天、一周，坦率地说，甚至是你童年积攒的压力。而且，我认为这非常重要的一点是，你可以把这些发泄在另一个人身上。
Pablo says that watching the minor league games, knowing that the human umpire was just the messenger for the robot empire and its perfect calls of balls and strikes--
帕布罗说，观看小联盟比赛时，知道真人裁判只是机器人帝国的传声筒，负责执行那些完美的球好坏判罚——
It felt like the equivalent of talking to a customer service rep that you know isn't a person. It's like, I get that you're making human noises, but it's eerie. And then realizing, oh, no, no-- I want a human. Because when you're getting mad at an umpire in these minor league, full ABS system games, you're just yelling at your computer monitor.
那感觉就像是在和一个你知道不是真人的客服代表交谈。就像是，我明白你在发出人类的声音，但这让人毛骨悚然。然后我意识到，不，不——我还是想要一个真人。因为当你在这些使用全套ABS系统的小联盟比赛中对裁判生气时，你其实只是在对着你的电脑屏幕大喊大叫。
Then this season-- I'm guessing a lot of you have heard this-- the robot umpires arrived in the major leagues. The ABS system went into every Major League Baseball park. And every game in those parks has used that technology. And the problem that Pablo had with ABS when he first saw it in the minors-- they fixed it. They fixed it completely and fully with a competence he had never expected from Major League Baseball. How'd they do it?
然后到了这个赛季——我猜你们很多人都听说了——机器人裁判来到了大联盟。ABS系统进入了每一个美国职业棒球大联盟球场。这些球场的每一场比赛都使用了这项技术。而帕布罗最初在小联盟看到ABS时遇到的问题——他们解决了。他们以一种帕布罗从未从大联盟身上期待过的能力，彻底、完全地解决了。他们是怎么做到的？
So explain for people who aren't watching baseball how the system works now.
那么，请为那些不看棒球的人解释一下现在的系统是如何运作的。
It's brilliant, the way it works now, and I didn't see it coming. The way it works is that it's not a computer telling the umpire in their ear, this is a ball, and this is a strike. What's happening instead is the umpire, the human being, is going about their job as they have for decades upon decades.
现在的运作方式非常巧妙，我完全没预料到。它是这样运作的：不是电脑在裁判耳边说这是好球或坏球。相反，裁判——那个真人——正如几十年来一样履行他们的职责。
So the umpire is calling the game, the way they always have.
所以裁判像往常一样判罚比赛。
Yes, except now there is a challenge system, in which the batter, the pitcher, the catcher, they can basically throw a flag and say, in so many words, I think the umpire messed up. And at that point, the robot, up on the jumbotron, they show you whether the umpire actually got it right or wrong. And what it did was, in this brilliant way, once again, we are judging a human being, the umpire.
是的，只不过现在有了挑战系统。击球手、投手、捕手，他们基本上可以扔出一面旗帜，换句话说，就是说：“我认为裁判搞错了。”在那一刻，大屏幕上的机器人会向你展示裁判到底是判对了还是判错了。这以一种绝妙的方式再次回到了我们是在评判一个人类裁判这一事实。
So to show just how satisfying that can be for fans, this is a game in Cincinnati in March. It's the Reds versus the Boston Red Sox. This is only three days after they started doing these challenges. Ryan Watson is pitching for Boston, and this is actually his very first game pitching Major League Baseball. And then in the sixth inning, Boston is behind 5 to 3. Cincinnati is at bat. Bases are loaded. They have two outs.
为了展示这对球迷来说有多么令人满意，这是三月份辛辛那提的一场比赛。红人队对阵波士顿红袜队。这距离他们开始实行这些挑战制度才三天。瑞安·沃森为波士顿投球，这实际上是他职业棒球大联盟的处子秀。然后在第六局，波士顿以3比5落后。辛辛那提队击球。满垒，两人出局。
A Red at every base, with two down.
每个垒包都有一个红人队队员，两人出局。
A player named Eugenio Suárez is at bat.
一个名叫尤金尼奥·苏亚雷斯的球员正在击球。
They're paying him to hit the ball out of the ballpark. This is certainly the moment of the game to this point. Here comes the 1-2. And in there! Struck him out! Now they're going to challenge this.
他们花钱请他把球打出球场。这无疑是比赛目前的关键时刻。1-2球数来了。进去了！三振！现在他们要挑战这个判罚。
Yeah. What you see is that the batter taps his helmet, which is a signal for, I initiate a challenge. I'm taking this to the court of appeals. And, immediately, on the jumbotron, you see the strike zone. And you see the electronic depiction of the ball. And we see that, in fact, the batter was right.
对。你看到击球手轻拍头盔，这是一个信号，表示“我发起挑战”。我要把它提交到上诉法院。然后，大屏幕上立即显示了好球带。你看到了球的电子轨迹。我们看到，事实上，击球手是对的。
ABS powered by T-Mobile-- that's out of the zone! The inning continues!
由T-Mobile驱动的ABS系统显示——那球出了好球带！比赛继续！
This was not a strike. It was a ball. And the umpire, in other words, has messed up.
这不是一个好球。是个坏球。换句话说，裁判搞错了。
And people love it.
人们很喜欢这个。
ABS could be a lot of fun, Mark!
ABS系统可以非常有趣，马克！
I mean, this game becomes this comedic chapter in the history of baseball. Because the very next pitch, another challenge. The batter says, you did it again. J'accuse again.
我的意思是，这场比赛成了棒球史上喜剧般的一章。因为紧接着的下一球，又是另一个挑战。击球手说：“你又搞错了。”再次抗议。
Called strike three, tapped the helmet again.
判为三振，再次轻拍头盔。
Batter's challengin' the pitch.
击球手正在挑战这一球。
Here we go.
开始吧。
[INDISTINCT CHATTER]
[模糊的交谈声]
[CROWD CHEERING]
[人群欢呼声]
Outside! The loudest cheers of the game. The Reds have hit two homers, come up back-to-back challenges!
偏外侧！这是全场最大的欢呼声。红人队击出了两支全垒打，连续发起挑战！
And now it's just like you almost begin to feel bad for CB Bucknor, the umpire, almost.
现在你几乎开始为裁判CB·巴克诺感到难过了，真的。
Oh, wow.
噢，哇。
[CROWD CHEERING]
[人群欢呼声]
Oh my god. People are standing. They're cheering. People are so excited.
我的天哪。人们都站起来了。他们在欢呼。人们太兴奋了。
It's so great. [LAUGHS] Look, in sports, you dream-- as a sports fan, you dream of stuff like this.
这太棒了。[笑声] 看，在体育运动中，你梦想——作为一名体育迷，你梦想着这样的事情。
Eugenio Suárez then hit the ball and was tagged out at first. But the Reds won. And-- most eye opening-- the umpire, CB Bucknor, had six of his calls overturned by the robot umpire in that game. That had never happened before in the Major Leagues. Pablo points out Major League Baseball could have gotten rid of the ump at the plate entirely, the way they got rid of line judges in tennis. They could have chosen perfect robot umpiring, perfect calls, balls and strikes like he gasbagged about years ago. But instead, they understood that one of the pleasures of the game is yelling.
尤金尼奥·苏亚雷斯随后击球并在垒位被触杀。但红人队赢了。而且——最令人大开眼界的是——裁判CB·巴克诺在那场比赛中被机器人裁判推翻了六次判罚。这在大联盟历史上从未发生过。帕布罗指出，美国职业棒球大联盟本可以完全取消本垒板后的裁判，就像他们在网球比赛中取消司线员一样。他们本可以选择完美的机器人裁判，实现他多年前吹牛时提到的那种完美的好球和坏球判罚。但相反，他们明白比赛的乐趣之一就是大喊大叫。
The fact is that there are few scenarios in American life, or anywhere that I can imagine, where you're empowered. You're legally, contractually allowed to go fucking nuts on the authority figure. Imagine doing that to a judge. You don't get to do that, except in sports.
事实是，在美国生活中，或者我能想象到的任何地方，很少有这样的场景：你有权这样做。你在法律上、合同上被允许对权威人物大吼大叫。想象一下对法官做这种事。除了在体育运动中，你没机会这样做。
Yeah. There's a quote from the guy who was the chairman of the committee that decided how to roll this out, this guy named John Stanton. And he said that the system that they chose to do retains the human side of the game, quote, "adding a new fan-friendly engagement moment."
是的。有一个来自负责推行这一制度的委员会主席约翰·斯坦顿的引言。他说他们选择的系统保留了比赛的人性化一面，引用他的话：“增加了一个新的、球迷友好的互动时刻。”
Yeah. I mean, let's be honest with what that is. A fan-friendly engagement moment is booing the shit out of umpires. That's what fan-friendly engagement means. It means let's give the coliseum some blood.
是的。我的意思是，让我们诚实地看待那是什么。所谓的“球迷友好互动时刻”就是对着裁判狂嘘。这就是球迷友好互动的含义。这意味着让我们给斗兽场增添一点血腥味。
Now, you and I are talking about this right now because I reached out to you, and I said, we're going to do an episode to commemorate our country's 250th anniversary. And we thought it would be nice to just celebrate and commemorate things that seem very, very American, like, especially American. How does this ABS challenge system fit the bill?
现在，你和我正在讨论这个，因为我联系了你，我说我们将制作一集来纪念我们国家建国250周年。我们认为纪念那些看起来非常、非常美国化的事情会很好。这个ABS挑战系统是如何符合这一点的？
Because America, if you're really cutting to the core of us, we want to be mad as much as we want justice. We want to be able to express what's inside of us that feels like it's trapped there as much as we want to see each getting their own fair due. And in this ABS system, what our pastime, our oldest, stodgiest, dustiest pastime has given us is somehow the ability to maybe have both.
因为美国人，如果你真正深入我们的核心，我们想获得正义的渴望和我们想发火的渴望一样强烈。我们希望能够表达内心深处那些感到受困的东西，就像我们希望看到每个人都得到应得的公平对待一样。而在这种ABS系统中，我们最古老、最陈旧、最灰暗的消遣方式，以某种方式赋予了我们同时做到这两点的能力。
Both, meaning we want justice, but we also want to scream at somebody. Hard not to think about what's going on in national politics when he puts it that way. Today on our show, for our July 4 semiquincentennial-- and, yes, I had to look that word up, which means 250th. According to the internet, actually, an alternative word for this is sestercentennial, but that just sounds like a very old nun. For our semiquincentennial, commemorating what this country has been for 250 years, we thought that it would be fun to collect a bunch of things that just seem very particularly American, like changing the rules of our national pastime to allow for more screaming at figures of authority.
两者兼得，意思是我们要正义，但我们也想对某人大喊大叫。当他这样说时，很难不联想到国家政治中正在发生的事情。今天在我们的节目中，为了我们的7月4日建国250周年纪念——是的，我不得不去查这个词，意思是250周年。根据互联网，这个词的替代说法是“sestercentennial”，但这听起来像个老修女。为了纪念这个国家250年来所经历的一切，我们认为收集一些看起来非常有美国特色的东西会很有趣，比如修改我们国球的规则，允许更多地对权威人物大吼大叫。
Today on our show, we have the most American question, we have a trip to a Michigan sand dune with our own question, and we have so much more. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，我们有最美国化的问题，我们有一次去密歇根沙丘的旅行，以及更多精彩内容。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
It's This American Life. Our semiquincentennial episode-- boy, that really does not roll off the tongue-- Act One, A Most American Question. So there are definitely are a bunch of questions that Americans have asked over our 250 years that seem very characteristically American. Are you now, or have you ever been, a member of the Communist Party? Do you want fries with that? Where are you from? With its classic companion, where are you really from? One of our contributors, Jiayang Fan, has her pick for the most American question out there.
这里是《美国生活》。我们的250周年纪念特辑——天哪，这名字真绕口——第一幕，最美国化的问题。在我们建国250年来，美国人确实问过很多非常具有美国特色的问题。你现在是，或者你曾经是共产党员吗？你要加份薯条吗？你是从哪里来的？以及它的经典配套问题，你到底是从哪里来的？我们的一位撰稿人，樊嘉扬，她选出了她心中最美国化的问题。
The first time I heard someone ask the question outside of an ESL class, I was eight years old. Are you OK? I knew so few English words that part of the reason why it registered so distinctly must have been the shock of understanding. Are you OK? A young police officer was asking my mother the question. He had been called, as the police were often called in our first days in America, to our basement apartment.
我第一次听到有人在英语课之外问这个问题时，我才八岁。“你还好吗？”（Are you OK?）我当时会的英语词汇太少了，以至于它给我留下如此深刻印象的原因，一定是因为听懂它时的那种冲击感。“你还好吗？”一个年轻的警察正在问我母亲这个问题。就像我们在美国初期经常叫警察一样，他被叫到了我们的地下室公寓。
My mother and I had recently reunited with my father after he'd left to study in America six years earlier. And it hadn't gone well. Doors were slammed, plates shattered, limbs pinned to the ground, ultimatums delivered. Usually, I hid in bed, under the covers, with palms pasted to my ears. But that day, the apartment was quiet. My father had already left for good. Did my mother call because she was being harassed by my father's mistress or because we were being evicted from our basement studio? I no longer remember.
我母亲和我刚与我父亲团聚，他六年前离开去美国学习。团聚并不顺利。门被猛地关上，盘子被摔碎，四肢被压在地板上，最后通牒被下达。通常我躲在被子里，手掌紧贴着耳朵。但那天，公寓很安静。我父亲已经彻底离开了。是我母亲因为被我父亲的情人骚扰，还是因为我们被赶出了地下室公寓而报警的？我已经记不清了。
I do remember that it was the first time I dared to look at an American police officer up close-- blue uniform, black boots, a belt heavy and crowded. My mother and I did not look to be in the way of bodily harm. There was nothing more for an officer of the law to do. Are you OK, ma'am?, the man asked as he stood in the doorway. The question hung in the air as a procedural formality, as a way of wrapping up the visit.
我记得那是第一次我敢近距离观察美国警察——蓝色的制服，黑色的靴子，一条沉重而挤满装备的腰带。我母亲和我看起来不像会受到身体伤害的样子。法律的执法人员已经没什么可做的了。“你还好吗，女士？”那人在门口问道。这个问题悬在空中，作为一种例行公事，作为结束访问的一种方式。
I had been in the country for less than a year. But I knew what the next words should be, the standard call and response, the same way that "how are you?" had only one answer. Fine, thank you. How are you? But that day, kneeling on the floor, face covered in her own tears and snot, my mother responded with something else. No, she said. The officer lowered himself onto the floor next to the doorjamb, then listened and nodded for an hour.
我在这个国家待了不到一年。但我知道接下来的话应该是什么，那种标准的应答，就像“你好吗？”只有一个回答一样。“我很好，谢谢。你好吗？”但那天，跪在地板上，脸上布满了泪水和鼻涕，我母亲却回答了别的东西。“不，”她说。警察在门框旁边蹲下来，然后听着并点头听了一个小时。
I was astonished. My mother followed rules tirelessly and taught me to do the same, all part of adapting as seamlessly as possible. Why would she embarrass herself like that? I didn't understand enough English to follow the conversation, but as I watched my mother closely, I was certain I would never break the script like that.
我很震惊。我母亲无条件地遵守规则，也教我这样做，这都是为了尽可能无缝地融入。她为什么要那样丢脸？我的英语还不足以跟上对话，但当我仔细观察母亲时，我确信我永远不会那样打破剧本。
I spent the next several years irritated with, are you OK? Compelled to be OK with it in public while fuming to my diary in private. Here's an entry from when I was 12. October 26, 1996-- Are you OK? Things going OK, right? Is everything OK? Those are the most common questions in America. I don't like them because they don't tell you anything about anything. Yes! Of course! Great! Those are the most common answers. Isn't that so cheap? I think so. Those questions are so pointless that it is even a waste of words to me.
接下来的几年里，我一直对“你还好吗？”感到厌烦。被迫在公共场合表现得“还好”，而在日记里私下里发火。这是我12岁时的一篇日记。1996年10月26日——“你还好吗？一切都好吗？没问题吧？”这些是美国最常见的问题。我不喜欢它们，因为它们什么也说不清楚。“是的！当然！很好！”这些是最常见的回答。这难道不是很廉价吗？我是这么认为的。这些问题毫无意义，对我来说甚至是在浪费言语。
As I saw it then, the question's hollowness had a distinctly American quality. Here, pleases, thank yous, excuse mes, weren't they always uttered ad nauseam from mouths of people who had already muscled past you? Are you OK was a question, supposedly. But how often was it really a mechanical reflex, an American tic announcing itself? Someone goes down hard in lacrosse practice, and the are you OK? arrives almost simultaneously with the impact. The question is a reflex, not an inquiry.
当时我认为，这种问题的空洞感具有鲜明的美国特质。在这里，“请”、“谢谢”、“打扰一下”，难道不是总是从那些已经挤过你身边的人嘴里没完没了地吐出来吗？“你还好吗”本是一个问题。但它有多少次真的只是一个机械反射，一个自我宣告的美国式习惯？有人在长曲棍球训练中摔得很重，“你还好吗？”几乎在撞击的同时就到了。这个问题是一种反射，而不是一种询问。
In our 37 years together, my mother and I were often and unmistakably not OK. Still, it was not a question we often asked of each other. That sort of check-in hit too close to the bone. Not Chinese, my mother would have certainly said, though I never pressed her on it-- also not Chinese.
在我们在一起的37年里，我和母亲经常且显然并不“好”。尽管如此，这并不是我们经常问对方的问题。那种关怀触及了太深处的痛点。“不是中国式的，”我母亲肯定会这么说，尽管我从未追问过——那也不是中国式的。
Lately, though, I've been thinking about the moment she told the police officer she wasn't OK. I thought she flubbed the obligatory call and response of the question. But now I wonder if it was something else. My mother is dead now, but the look on her face as she knelt and cried with a stranger still comes to me sometimes. It arrives most vividly, unbidden, when I'm with friends or mothers, watching their kids on the neighborhood playground.
不过最近，我一直在想她告诉警察她不好的那一刻。我原以为她搞砸了那个问题的标准应答。但现在我想也许是别的原因。我母亲现在去世了，但她跪着和一个陌生人哭泣时的表情有时仍会浮现在我脑海中。它最生动、最突兀地出现的时候，是我和朋友或母亲们在一起，看着她们的孩子在社区游乐场玩耍时。
A scrape on the knee or the elbow, the wound still red and angry, and someone-- a mother, a friend-- administers the question. And there, on the child's open mouth and tears-smeared face, is my mother's shocked look. The child hears the question. It doesn't make the pain go away. But the question stays in the air. It becomes a pause, a door held open.
膝盖或手肘上的擦伤，伤口仍然红肿愤怒，然后有人——一位母亲，一个朋友——抛出了那个问题。在那孩子张开的嘴和泪痕斑斑的脸上，就是我母亲当年那个震惊的表情。孩子听到了这个问题。它并不能让疼痛消失。但这个问题停留在空气中。它变成了一个停顿，一扇敞开的门。
Jiayang Fan. She's a staff writer at The New Yorker. That story was produced by Diane Wu.
樊嘉扬。《纽约客》专栏作家。那个故事由黛安·吴制作。
Act Two, City on a Hill, of Sand. We here in the land of the free do not like to be told what to do. And additionally, and maybe especially, we don't like to be told what not to do. Aviva DeKornfeld has a story about that very American quality as it plays out in one of our shared public spaces.
第二幕，沙丘上的山中之城。我们这些自由之地的人不喜欢被告知该怎么做。此外，也许尤其是，我们不喜欢被告知不该做什么。阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德有一个关于这种美国特质在我们共享的公共空间中如何表现的故事。
I went to Sleeping Bear Dunes National Lakeshore to see the star attraction, the tallest dune in the park. It's 450 feet high and slopes down at what looks like a 45-degree angle directly into Lake Michigan. If you can't picture 450 feet, imagine a 34-story building. The grade is so steep that from the bottom of the dune, you can't even see up to the top. It's just a wall of sand in front of you.
我去了睡熊沙丘国家湖岸公园看那里的主打景点，公园里最高的沙丘。它高450英尺，以大约45度的坡度直接倾斜入密歇根湖。如果你无法想象450英尺，想象一下34层高的建筑。坡度如此陡峭，从沙丘底部你甚至看不见顶部。你面前只是一堵沙墙。
Oh my gosh.
噢，天哪。
Be careful.
小心。
Good luck.
祝你好运。
All right. Let's get over here. Let's do it. Thank you so much.
好了。到这边来。我们开始吧。非常感谢。
Take your time.
慢慢来。
People come from all over the Midwest to walk down this dune and then promptly turn around and trudge right back up. There's only a 2-foot-wide strip of beach at the bottom, so turning around is about all there is to do. This climb is not for everyone. Dozens need assistance climbing out each summer. And because of that, the park service tries to discourage people from climbing the dune without prohibiting it outright.
人们从整个中西部赶来，走下这座沙丘，然后迅速转身，费力地爬上来。底部只有一条2英尺宽的海滩，所以转身基本上就是唯一能做的事情。这种攀爬并不适合每个人。每年夏天都有几十人需要救援才能出来。正因为如此，公园管理局试图劝阻人们在没有明确禁止的情况下攀爬沙丘。
They've tried a bunch of different signs. The current one mentions the ecological damage of walking on the dune and says "Down is optional," which is intentionally soft language because their previous signs said that there'd be a $3,000 rescue fee, which Americans seem to take as a kind of personal challenge, and even more people attempted the climb.
他们尝试过各种标牌。现在的标牌提到了在沙丘上行走造成的生态破坏，并写着“向下走是可选的”，这是特意柔和的语言，因为他们之前的标牌上说会有3000美元的救援费，美国人似乎把这当成了一种个人挑战，反而有更多人尝试攀登。
Park rangers also patrol the top ridge, asking visitors about their intentions with the dune. Here's Jen, the aggressively mild-mannered ranger on the job today, talking with some prospective climbers.
公园巡逻员也会在山脊顶部巡逻，询问游客攀爬沙丘的意图。这是珍，今天当班的、性格极其温和的巡逻员，正在与一些潜在的攀登者交谈。
It's a lot harder than it looks. I will tell you that.
这比看起来难得多。我告诉你。
Oh, I understand that.
噢，我理解。
And it's all sand. Yeah, so it is a very challenging climb. Usually, people on the bottom half are using all fours, basically, to get back up. So it's very challenging. But yeah, I think the view is best at the top.
而且全是沙子。是的，所以这是一次非常有挑战性的攀登。通常，下半段的人基本上得手脚并用才能爬回去。所以这非常困难。但是，是的，我认为顶部的风景最好。
Approximately 8 feet away from Jen sits Jim. He's part of the team of volunteers helping rangers deter people.
距离珍大约8英尺远的地方坐着吉姆。他是帮助巡逻员劝阻人们的志愿者团队的一员。
My job up here is to try to save them from themselves, let them know how high this hill is--
我在这里的工作是试图把他们从自己手中拯救出来，让他们知道这座山有多高——
Jim's been volunteering for almost a decade.
吉姆已经做了近十年的志愿者。
--and the hazards of going--
——以及攀爬的危险。
He sits on his chair, wearing his bright orange volunteer vest, pimped out with various pins and patches he's earned over the years, including, proudly, a Junior Ranger badge.
他坐在椅子上，穿着鲜艳的橙色志愿者背心，背心上别满了这些年来他获得的各种徽章和补丁，其中包括他引以为傲的“初级巡逻员”徽章。
This is my 86th summer up here.
这是我在山上的第86个夏天了。
Oh my gosh.
噢，我的天。
Just love it. Yeah.
就是喜欢这里。是的。
Wow.
哇。
Jim's seen all kinds of ill-advised behavior-- people heading down without water, without shoes, without their inhaler, and worst of all, as far as Jim is concerned, running down the dune.
吉姆见过各种不明智的行为——人们不带水、不穿鞋、不带哮喘吸入器就往下冲，而且据吉姆所知，最糟糕的是，有人竟然从沙丘上跑下去。
We had a girl get badly hurt here. She ran down. She tripped. She vaulted out, tried to stop herself. She dislocated both shoulders, broke a collarbone, wrenched her neck, hurt her back, and cut her head on a rock.
我们有个女孩在这里受了重伤。她跑着下去。她被绊倒了。她跳了出去，试图停下来。她双肩脱臼，锁骨骨折，脖子扭伤，背部受伤，头上撞到石头上划开了。
Oh my god.
我的天哪。
Standing on the ridge, you can see the slope filled with dozens of people, heads down, slowly, silently trudging up the hill, scores of people who were told not to do this and decided to try it anyway.
站在山脊上，你可以看到斜坡上挤满了数十人，低着头，默默地缓慢爬山，许多被告知不要这样做却还是决定试一试的人。
How you feeling down here?
你在下面感觉怎么样？
I feel good. This is what we came for.
我感觉很好。这就是我们来的目的。
At the very bottom of the hill, I met Michael and his daughter, Kalea, who drove here from Georgia.
在山脚下，我遇到了迈克尔和他的女儿卡莉亚，他们从佐治亚州开车来到这里。
The lady at the place that you check in at, she suggested that you not do this. She said, I advise y'all against it. All the park rangers say not to do it.
办理入住的地方的那位女士建议不要这样做。她说，我建议你们不要这样做。所有的公园巡逻员都说不要这样做。
And yet, you guys thought, huh.
然而，你们却想，呵。
Well, we drove a thousand miles to get here, so yes, we're going to do it.
好吧，我们开车一千英里才到这儿，所以是的，我们要这样做。
Yeah. And you're not worried about going back up.
是的。而且你不担心怎么爬回去吗？
No. She plays soccer, and I train with her. So we're ready to go. We're supposed to race back up, but--
不。她踢足球，我和她一起训练。所以我们准备好了。我们应该要赛着爬回去，但是——
I think I'm the subject of peer pressure.
我想我成了同伴压力的受害者。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Half an hour later, I found Michael again, only about a third of the way up.
半小时后，我再次遇到了迈克尔，他只爬了大约三分之一的路程。
How you feeling?
你感觉怎么样？
Lord. Hopefully, I make it. [LAUGHS] Slow and steady. I knew it was going to be hard, but it's harder than I thought it would be.
天哪。希望我能坚持到底。[笑声] 慢而稳。我知道会很难，但这比我想象的要难得多。
A little further up the hill, I spot another guy named Michael. He's wearing an oversized visor and has blue braces on his teeth. He was part of a whole crew wearing matching hats, celebrating his 50th birthday, if you could call this celebrating.
在山上稍微高一点的地方，我发现了另一个名叫迈克尔的人。他戴着一个巨大的遮阳帽，牙齿上戴着蓝色牙套。他是穿着配套帽子的一群人中的一员，正在庆祝他的50岁生日，如果这也能叫庆祝的话。
How are you feeling now?
你现在感觉怎么样？
Tired. Humbling, you know. Every step you take up, you lose at least half of it going backwards, but yeah.
累。很羞愧，你知道吗。你每向上走一步，就会向后倒退一半，但是是的。
One guy, who had taken off his sand-filled sneakers and slung them over his neck, kept muttering to himself, like a mantra, I should have listened to my wife. I should have listened to my wife. The reason why you're not hearing that on tape is because it was so hard to move around the dune, zigzagging from person to person.
有一个人，他脱掉了装满沙子的运动鞋，挂在脖子上，一直在喃喃自语，像句咒语：“我本该听我妻子的。我本该听我妻子的。”你之所以在录音中没听到这个，是因为在沙丘上走来走去、从一个人绕过另一个人实在太难了。
[PANTING] Oh my god.
[喘气] 我的天哪。
I don't think it's a stretch to say we are a country of people who have been told over and over that we are the exception. So many of our movies, so many of the stories we tell ourselves are about how the rules, the warnings, the statistics, those are for other people. When we hear that most people can't do something, we are trained to think, well, I'm not most people.
说我们是一个被反复告知自己是“例外”的国家的人民，这并不夸张。我们那么多的电影，我们告诉自己的那么多的故事，都是关于规则、警告、统计数据是如何为其他人制定的。当我们听到大多数人做不到某事时，我们被训练成认为：嗯，我不是大多数人。
But really, when we try to live out this pint-sized American exceptionalism, we are just as likely to find ourselves face down in the sand, panting and humbled, less city on a hill and more bear-crawling up it.
但实际上，当我们试图活出这种小型的“美国例外论”时，我们同样很可能会发现自己脸朝下趴在沙子里，喘着气，感到羞愧，与其说是山上的城市，不如说是艰难地爬山。
How are you feeling?
你感觉怎么样？
Like death.
像死了一样。
I noticed that you are on your hands and knees.
我注意到你现在四肢着地了。
Yep. Really rethinking life choices right now. [PANTING] I'm just tired. Are we halfway there yet?
是的。现在真的在重新反思生活选择。[喘气] 我只是累了。我们要到一半了吗？
I don't think we're halfway there yet.
我想还没到一半。
That's a bitch.
那真是个混蛋。
Are you on vacation?
你在度假吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Why would you spend your vacation doing something so punishing? Is your life not hard enough?
为什么你要把假期花在做这种折磨人的事情上？你的生活还不够难吗？
Oh, no, it sucks. I work my ass off all the time, so yeah.
噢，不，这太烂了。我一直拼命工作，所以是的。
This is just another day in the life.
这只是生活中的又一天。
Yep.
是的。
Kids seem to have a much easier time than adults. The top of the hill was full of children who, because of their tiny body weight, scampered like water beetles on top of the sand up to the ridge and then had the pleasure of watching the adults who usually boss them around huff and puff 300 feet below them. I met an 11-year-old and his little brother waiting for their parents.
孩子们似乎比成年人轻松得多。山顶上全是孩子们，由于他们微小的体重，他们像水黾一样在沙子上轻快地跑到山脊上，然后就有幸看着平时指挥他们的成年人在300英尺下气喘吁吁。我遇到了一个11岁的孩子和他的弟弟在等他们的父母。
He's five.
他才五岁。
You're five, and you went all the way to the bottom?
你才五岁，你就一直走到底部了？
Yeah, we went to the water.
是的，我们去水边了。
And then we goed all the way to the top. And he--
然后我们就一直走到顶上。他——
Faster than our whole family.
比我们全家人都快。
Wow.
哇。
He doesn't even have capped knees yet. So I--
他的膝盖甚至还没长好呢。所以我——
What? Is that true? I thought you got knees when you were like-- could walk.
什么？是真的吗？我以为你走路的时候就有膝盖了。
No. You know your kneecaps?
不。你知道你的膝盖骨吗？
Yeah.
是的。
You get them when you're 10. It makes it harder to climb.
你10岁的时候才会有。那会让爬山变难。
What? Like this?
什么？像这样？
Your kneecap.
你的膝盖骨。
You get that when you're 10?
你10岁时才会有那个？
Do you actually?
真的吗？
Yeah.
我能看看你的膝盖吗？
Can I see your knees?
看起来一样。那是内部，膝盖骨。
They look the same. It's the inside, kneecap.
呵。
Huh.
我带着我完全长好的膝盖骨走向吉姆，继续我们的谈话。他开始阐述他是如何建议人们的。
I walk over to Jim with my fully-formed kneecaps and pick up our conversation. He started expounding on how he counsels people.
好吧，如果我开始告诉人们这是什么样的感觉，然后——老鹰！
Well, if I start to tell people about what it's like and-- eagle!
一只秃鹰飞过头顶。我们都转过头去看着。我们就这样站着，一群美国人在一个完美的夏日，在一个因我们的行为而正在被破坏、又由我们的税款来维护的公园里的沙丘上，看着我们的吉祥物在天空中翱翔，对我们下面的困境漠不关心。
A bald eagle flew overhead. We all turned and looked. And there we stood, a bunch of Americans on a perfect summer day, on a dune in a park being destroyed by our actions and maintained by our tax dollars, watching our mascot soar through the sky, indifferent to our plight below.
阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德是我们节目的制作人之一。那个故事由莫莉·马塞洛共同制作。接下来，数千英里外在小岛上的美国人，在重建一些关于家乡的非常美国化的事情，无论他们是否有意为之。从芝加哥公共广播电台，节目将在片刻后继续。
Aviva DeKornfeld is one of the producers of our program. That story was co-produced by Molly Marcello. Coming up, Americans thousands of miles away on tiny islands, recreating some very American things about home, whether they intend to or not. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目——极致的美国化。为了纪念我们国家250周年诞辰，我们准备了一些看起来非常、特别地美国化的故事。我们现在来到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，库克岛（Cooked Island）。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program-- Maximal Americanness. For our nation's 250th birthday, we have stories about things that seem very especially and particularly American. We've arrived at act three of our program. Act Three, Cooked Island.
接下来的这一幕，执行编辑伊曼纽尔·贝里加入了我们的录音室。你好。
For this next act, I'm joined in the studio by our executive editor, Emanuele Berry. Hello.
嘿。
Hey, there.
你在这里是因为第一，电视是一个非常美国的发明。然后作为一个国家，我们通过创造一个更美国化的事物——现实类电视节目，超越了这一点。而你在这里是为了告诉我们这一切之上的那种“樱桃”？
And you are here because one, a very American invention was television. And then we as a nation topped that by creating an even more American thing, which is reality TV. And you are here to tell us about the kind of cherry on top of all of that?
是的。我要介绍现实类电视节目中最美国化的一季。
Yes. I'm going to present the most American season of reality TV.
我得说，你看过很多现实类节目。所以是哪一季？
And I should say, you watch a lot of reality TV. So what season is it?
好吧。我们要谈论的是《幸存者》第13季。
All right. We are talking about season 13 of Survivor.
《幸存者》是那个老牌真人秀，把一群人放在岛上，分成小组，参加挑战，然后有人被投票出局，对吧？
And Survivor is the old-school reality show where they stick a bunch of people on an island and divide them into teams, and they compete in challenges, and then people get voted off, right?
是的。没错。这是《幸存者》，经典的节目。我们都知道。我想谈论的这一季《幸存者》，被我和其他粉丝称为“种族战争”季。我们这样称呼它是因为在这一季里，他们按种族划分了部落。有一个非裔美国人部落，一个白人部落，一个亚裔美国人部落，还有一个拉美裔部落。我知道这不算种族，但他们就是这么分的。
Yes. Yes, yes. That's Survivor, classic show. We all know it. And so the season of Survivor I want to talk about is what me, other Survivor fans call the race war season. And we call it that because in this season, they divided the tribes up by race. So there's an African-American tribe. There's a white tribe. There's an Asian-American tribe. There's a Latino tribe. I know that's not a race, but that's how they divided the tribes.
好的。这看起来是一个极其敏感和疯狂的做法。他们为什么要这样做？
OK. So that seems like an incredibly loaded and crazy thing to do. Why did they do this?
基本上，《幸存者》因为选角不够多样化而受到了很多批评。不仅如此，很多时候，当他们走到季终时，剩下的只有白人选手。
So basically, Survivor had gotten a lot of criticism because the casting just wasn't very diverse. And on top of that, a lot of times, they would get to the end of the season, and it would only be the white players left.
噢，非白人选手会很早就被投票出局。
Oh, the nonwhite players would get voted off early.
是的。所以这就是他们对此的回应。他们就像是：“好吧，你们想要更多多样性，这是更多多样性”，这是一种选择。
Yes. So this was their response to that. They were like, OK, you guys want more diversity, here is more diversity, which is a choice.
你得尊重他们这种加倍努力的态度。节目中的参赛者对此感觉如何？
You have to respect them for kind of doubling down. How did the contestants on the show feel about it?
参赛者似乎对此感到困惑。他们就像是：“为什么要把它变成关于种族的事情？”
So the contestants seemed kind of confused by it. They're like, why did we make this about race?
不同的族群——我的意思是，这合适吗？
Different ethnic groups-- I mean, is that kosher?
我当时真的惊呆了。我的意思是，这太疯狂了。一方面，我认为这是一个很好的机会，因为有更多的少数族裔是非常棒的。同时，我也有些担心这可能会导致刻板印象和陈词滥调。
I honestly was stunned. I mean, this was crazy. I mean, on one hand, I think it's a great opportunity because I think it's wonderful that there's more minorities. At the same time, I'm a little bit worried that it might play out to caricatures and stereotypes.
我记得看节目时，刚开始那一季我真的很震惊，因为我想：“我真不敢相信他们会这样做。”但老实说，我很快就走出来了，因为基本上，第一季发生了一些事情，改变了我看待它的方式。从那以后，事情就一直发生。
I remember watching the show and being really shocked when I first started the season because I was like, I can't believe that they did this, but honestly, got over it really quick because basically, something happened in the first season that switched the way I was seeing it. And from there on, it just kept happening.
那么发生了什么？
So what happened?
他们以一种非常戏剧化的方式开始了这一季。他们在南太平洋中间的一艘船上。主持人杰夫·普罗布斯特告诉所有参赛者去收集物资，坐上木筏，和你的团队一起去岸边。
So they start the season in this really dramatic way. They're on a boat in the middle of the South Pacific. And the host, Jeff Probst, is telling all the contestants to gather supplies, get on a raft, and go to shore with your team.
他们有两分钟时间来抢救船上能抢到的任何东西。
They've been given two minutes to salvage whatever they can off this boat.
杰夫说：“你们有两分钟。尽可能多地抢东西。”
And Jeff's like, you have two minutes. Grab as much as you can.
你需要抓住那只鸡。那是你想吃的食物。
You need to catch that chicken. That is food you are going to want.
所以他们尽量多抢，到达了岛上。然后发生了一件事，这其实在任何一季《幸存者》中都可能发生，那就是：一个部落的人偷了另一个部落的鸡。但因为这一季大家是按种族划分的，我不由得注意到是白人部落从亚裔部落偷了鸡。我看着这个，我想：“呃，太‘白’了。”[笑声]
So they grab as much as they can, get to the island. And then this thing happens that, really, it could happen on any season of Survivor, which is, someone from one of the tribes steals chickens from the other tribe. But because this season everyone's divided by race, it's like, I kind of can't help but notice that it was the white tribe that stole the chicken from the Asian tribe. And so I'm watching this and I'm thinking, ugh, that is so white. [LAUGHS]
我明白了。
I see that.
但后来我想：“呃，为什么我会有这种想法？”这就像是在反思我自己的偏见，思考我如何看待种族问题，对吧？
But then I'm like, ugh, why did I even think that? Like, looking at my own biases and thinking about how I'm thinking about race, right?
噢，所以你经历了这样一种状态，发现自己一次又一次地问：“这是种族问题，还是我自己的问题？”
Oh, so you're having this thing where you're finding yourself asking over and over, is that race, or is that me?
是的。所以这一切都在前几集里发生了。然后制片人决定：“你知道吗？让我们结束这种隔离吧。”他们混合了团队。就像他们完全放弃了这一季最初的前提。现在每个人都在一个整合后的团队里，基本上。但问题是，因为他们一开始是隔离的，种族问题似乎仍然悬在整个事情上。
Yeah. So all that is happening in the first few episodes. And then the producers decide, you know what? Let's end this segregation thing. They're like, mix up the teams. Like, they completely abandoned this initial premise of the season. And everybody is now on integrated teams, basically. But the thing is, because they started out segregated, the race thing is sort of still hanging over the whole thing.
然后发生了一个转折。就在挑战之前。两个部落聚集在一起。杰夫说：“我们要在这里尝试一些不同的东西。”
And then there's this twist that happens. It's right before a challenge. And the two tribes have gathered. And Jeff says, we're going to try something different here.
“我给你们每个人提供叛变的机会。”
I'm offering each of you the opportunity to mutiny.
这本质上意味着你可以放弃你的部落，去加入另一个部落。
Which essentially means you can abandon your tribe and go and join the other tribe.
这会以一种种族紧张的方式展开吗？
And does this play out in a racially charged way?
[笑声] 嗯，唯一变动的人是两个白人选手。他们去加入了另一个部落里的白人选手。我得说——他们这样做可能是因为他们和那些人关系密切，或者有很多原因。但在看着他们走过去的那一刻，很难不想：“嗯，白人逃离（white flight）。”
[LAUGHS] Well, the only people who switch are two white players. So they go and join the other white players on the other tribe. And just to say-- they could have done it because they had close relationships with those people, or lots of reasons that they could have done this. But it's hard not to think, watching them walk across to the other side, hmm, white flight.
[笑声]
[LAUGHTER]
因为这样做彻底制造了两个极不平衡的部落。剩下一个四人的部落——他们抛弃的部落——有四个有色人种。而另一个部落现在有八个人——四个白人，两个亚裔，一个黑人和一个拉美裔。
Because what it does is it totally creates these two lopsided tribes. So there's one tribe of four left, the tribe they abandoned, which has four POC. And then the other tribe has now eight people-- four white people, two Asian people, one Black person, and one Hispanic person.
等等。一个部落的规模是另一个的两倍。那一定给了他们优势，对吧？
And wait. And so one tribe is twice as big as the other. So that must give them an advantage, right?
在很多方面确实如此。我想他们认为：“噢，我们很快就要扫荡另一个部落了。他们不可能赢得任何挑战。”但实际上发生的事情恰恰相反。那个四人的小部落——他们叫他们“Aitu四人组”，那个人有色人种联盟——他们基本上打出了《幸存者》史上最伟大的表现之一。从那以后，他们赢得了每一场挑战，尽管他们的人数是2比1。
It does in a lot of ways. I think they think, like, oh, we're about to sweep this other tribe. There's no way they're going to win any challenges. And what happens actually is kind of the exact opposite. So the little tribe of four, which is-- they call them the Aitu Four, the little POC coalition-- they basically go on, I would say, one of the greatest runs in Survivor history. So they win every single challenge from then on out, even though they're outnumbered 2 to 1.
再次，当我观看时，很难不想：“嗯，必须比别人优秀两倍，对吧？”所有这些有色人种都不得不变得更聪明、更努力，做所有这些事情才留在平等的竞争环境中获胜。每次他们获胜，对方就必须参加部落理事会。他们踢走一个有色人种，直到最后，这变成了一件非常鲜明的事情：最后是四个白人对四个有色人种。
And again, as I'm watching this, it's kind of hard not to think, huh, got to be twice as good, right? It's all these people of color who are having to be smarter and work harder and do all of these things just to stay on the even playing field to win, essentially. And each time they win, the other team has to go to tribal council. They kick off a person of color, until finally, it kind of becomes this very stark thing, where it's down to four white people versus four people of color at the end--
我的天哪。
Oh my god.
——两个联盟。
--two alliances.
制片人得到了他们想要的。
The producers got what they wanted.
算是吧。是的，对吧？然后那个有色人种部落继续获胜。然后他们一个接一个地把白人选手投出局。
Kind of. Yeah, right? And then that tribe that is the POC tribe, they keep winning. And then they vote all the white contestants off one by one.
所以当你看到这一切在季终时是如何展现的，为什么你认为这是现实类电视节目中最美国化的一季？
And so when you see how all of this played out by the end of the season, why do you think of this as the most American season of reality TV?
因为总体而言，在这个国家，我们不想谈论种族。我们不想被迫去思考种族。
Because in general, in this country, we don't want to talk about race. We don't want to have to think about race.
不，我们不想。
No, we do not.
然后我们被迫进入这些我们别无选择的情况。我们必须谈论它。它又出现了，各位。惊喜吧。
And then we are forced into these situations where we have no choice. We have to talk about it. It's come up again, you guys. Surprise.
是的。事情就是这样。
Yeah. Things happen.
而在这一季里，我们一次又一次地经历这种体验。对我来说，这是美国体验中如此典型的一部分。而这一切都在南太平洋中间一个该死的岛屿上的比赛中展现出来。
And then in this season, we have that experience over and over and over again. And to me, it is such a quintessential part of the American experience. And it's all playing out in this game on a frickin' island in the middle of the South Pacific.
伊曼纽尔·贝里是我们节目的执行编辑。
Emanuele Berry is the executive editor of our program.
第四幕，最美国化的教科书。罗曼·马斯主持着播客《99%隐形》。他最近和BBC开始了一个新的系列节目，叫《100个对象讲述美国史》。他新节目中的一个故事与我们今天讨论的话题非常契合。它是关于一本影响了美国教育多年的书。有请罗曼。
Act Four, The Most American Schoolbook. So Roman Mars hosts the podcast 99% Invisible. And he recently started a new series with the BBC. It's called A History of the United States in 100 Objects. And one of the stories on his new show seemed very much in line with what we're talking about here today on our show. It is about a book that shaped education in this country for years. Here's Roman.
我要告诉你的这本书是一个非常沮丧的学校老师写的。这家伙在1783年教书。独立战争即将结束，美国本土的战斗终于逐渐平息。在日常生活的每一个角落，人们都在想：“好吧，既然我们不再是英国人了，成为美国人到底意味着什么？”
The book I'm going to tell you about was written by one very frustrated schoolteacher. This guy is teaching in 1783. The Revolutionary War is ending, the fighting on American soil finally tapering off. And in every part of regular life, people are trying to figure out, OK, now that we're not British anymore, what does it actually mean to be an American?
这个老师，他在一间单室校舍里教育着50到70名学生。这些学生年龄从6岁到16岁不等。全国很多地方都是这样。只有极少数孩子能接受教育。即使他们进了教室，也没有统一的课程，没有共享的教材或流程。学生们使用的书是英国的，教授的是英国地理、英国历史、英国人的思维方式。人们大多还在用带“u”的拼写方式写“color”（颜色）。
This teacher, he's educating anywhere from 50 to 70 students in a one-room schoolhouse. And these students range from 6 to 16 years old. It's the same in a lot of places around the country. A very small percentage of kids are getting an education. And even if they do get into a classroom, there's no standard curriculum, no shared set of books or processes. The books these students are using are British, teaching British geography, British history, British ways of thinking. People are largely still spelling the word "color" with a U.
而这位老师，他环顾这一切，决定：这必须改变。他的名字叫诺亚·韦伯斯特。
And the schoolteacher, he looks around at all of this and decides, this has to change. His name is Noah Webster.
作为一个教育者，他承担了识字的问题。
He's this person who takes on, as an educator, the problem of literacy.
那是伊曼妮·佩里，哈佛大学教授，非裔美国人研究学者。
That's Imani Perry, author and professor of African-American studies at Harvard University.
他抱怨教室拥挤、嘈杂且混乱。他还致力于寻找一种使美国学习标准化方式。
And he complains about the classrooms being crowded and noisy and chaotic. And he is also interested in trying to find a way to standardize American learning.
所以，早在他的字典让他家喻户晓之前，韦伯斯特就自掏腰包印了一本小蓝书，名字很长，叫《英语语法研究所第一部分》，书名糟糕到没人用。大家只是开始称它为《蓝皮拼写书》。
So long before his dictionary made him a household name, Webster spends his own money to print a little blue book with an unwieldy title. It's called The First Part of the Grammatical Institute of the English Language, a title so bad that nobody ever used it. They just started calling it the Blue-Back Speller.
他确实创作了这本为自学者准备的书。这是一种自学方式。这不是字典。它确实是一本学习阅读的指南。
So he really creates this book that is built for an autodidact. It's a way to self-teach. It's not a dictionary. It really is like a guide to learning to read.
如果听起来有些矛盾，说你通过一本需要你阅读的书来学习阅读，它的工作原理是这样的：这本书包含了一堆练习，看起来有点像乘法表，但包含你需要记忆的单词和字母。首先，你从学习字母表开始——A、B、C、D。然后你移动到音节，比如ah、ba、cah和da，直到你最终学会简单的单词，比如bag、big、bog、bug。最终，你组成句子，阅读段落。然后你会读这些短故事，一系列寓言和道德寓言。
If it sounds kind of counterintuitive that you'd learn to read from a book that requires you to read, here's how that worked. The book contains a bunch of exercises that kind of look like multiplication tables, but with words and letters that you'd memorize. First, you'd start by learning the alphabet-- A, B, C, D. And then you'd move to syllables, like ah, ba, cah, and da, until you finally learn simple words, like bag, big, bog, bug. Eventually, you'd form sentences, read paragraphs. And then you'd read these short stories, a collection of fables and moral parables.
韦伯斯特用这本书引入了更简单、更具美国特色的拼写。他去掉了“humor”和“labor”中的“u”。他曾经建议我们把“daughter”拼成D-A-W-T-E-R，那会很好，虽然那个拼法没流行起来。但他的宏大想法成功了。这本书，《蓝皮拼写书》，成为早期美国最重要的书籍之一。整整几代人是在它的陪伴下长大的。
Webster uses the book to introduce simpler, more distinctly American spellings. He drops the U from humor and labor. He once suggested that we start spelling the word daughter as D-A-W-T-E-R, which would have been nice, though that one didn't stick. But his larger idea does succeed. This book, the Blue-Back Speller, becomes one of the most important books in early America. Entire generations grew up with it.
有一段时间，《蓝皮拼写书》的销量仅次于《圣经》。它也算是一种圣经。你能描述一下它的尺寸及其尺寸的相关性吗？
At one point, the Blue-Back Speller was second only to the Bible in copies sold. And it also is kind of like a bible. Could you describe its size and the relevance of its size?
是的。拿一本在手里感觉很棒，因为你意识到它是口袋大小的。它小到足以塞进夹克口袋或裤子口袋。它是可移动的。
Yeah. It's wonderful to hold one because you realize it's pocket sized. It was small enough to fit into a jacket pocket or pants pocket. It was mobile.
是的。而且它可以被隐藏。
Yeah. And it could be hidden.
它可以很容易地被藏起来，这非常重要。
It could easily be hidden, which was really important.
重要，因为它意味着这本书可以被不被允许拥有它的人秘密使用，那些被奴役的人，在法律上被禁止学习阅读。韦伯斯特可能根本没打算把这本书给黑人。虽然他反对奴隶制，但韦伯斯特的书是为美国人准备的，韦伯斯特在他的字典里将美国人定义为欧洲人的后裔——白人。
Important because it means the book could be used secretly by people who weren't supposed to have it, enslaved people, who were legally prohibited from learning to read. Webster probably never intended this book for Black people at all. While he was against slavery, Webster's books were meant for Americans, who were defined by Webster, in his dictionary, as descendants of Europeans-- white people.
尽管如此，《蓝皮拼写书》成为非裔美国人争取识字斗争的基础。
And despite that fact, his Blue-Back Speller becomes something that is fundamental to African-American struggles for literacy.
《蓝皮拼写书》到处都是，太常见了，以至于一些被奴役的人无论如何都设法弄到了它，即使在南部大部分地区，教被奴役的人识字实际上是违法的。
The Blue-Back Speller was everywhere, so common that some enslaved people managed to get their hands on it anyway, even though teaching an enslaved person to read was actually against the law in much of the South.
对于一个被奴役的人来说，拥有一本这样的拼写书可能会让你面临巨大的致残、死亡或被卖掉的风险。黑人识字被视为一种威胁。
Having one of these spellers, for someone who was enslaved, could put you at enormous risk of maiming, of death, of being sold. Black literacy was seen as a threat.
通过这种方式学习阅读的人之一是弗雷德里克·道格拉斯。他后来成为美国历史上最有影响力的作家和思想家之一，亚伯拉罕·林肯的顾问。
One of the enslaved people who learned to read this way was Frederick Douglass. He'd go on to become one of the most influential writers and thinkers in American history, an advisor to Abraham Lincoln.
他和无数其他黑人拿起那本《蓝皮拼写书》，坚持要成为识字的美国公众的一部分。我们看到这种情况的早期方式之一是内战中的黑人士兵，他们变得识字，并立即开始写信给林肯，说他们不仅希望在获得自由后拥有土地，而且必须有学校。
He and countless other Black people take on that Blue-Back Speller and insist upon becoming part of the literate American public. And one of the early ways we see this is Black soldiers in the Civil War who become literate and immediately begin writing letters to Lincoln, saying not only are they hopeful for land with their freedom, but there have to be schools.
《蓝皮拼写书》从造船厂走向城镇广场，从新英格兰的校舍走向南部的种植园。老实说，当我真的拿到它时，书的内容本身是一场无趣的苦役。如果你让我用《蓝皮拼写书》教别人阅读，那会很难。而且我无法想象从根本不会阅读开始，用它来摸索识字。它只是把你直接扔进游泳池的深水区，游在满是难以导航的表格的页面里。
The Blue-Back Speller found its way from shipyard to town square, from the schoolhouses of New England to the plantations of the South. And when I actually got my hands on it, if I'm being honest, the content of the book itself is kind of a joyless slog. If you asked me to teach someone to read using the Blue-Back Speller, it would be hard. And I can't imagine starting from a place of not being able to read at all and using it to navigate my way to literacy. It just throws you right into the deep end of the pool, swimming in pages of hard-to-navigate tables.
还有那些道德寓言。它们并不完全引人入胜，而且更多地带有说教意味。如果你是一个没有受过小学教育的人，这看起来完全就是那种可能会让你永远对阅读感到厌倦的书。
And then there are the moral parables. They're not exactly compelling and more than a little condescending. If you were someone who didn't get a primary school education, this seems like exactly the kind of book that might put you off of reading forever.
使用这本书需要真正的信念。它基本上把从幼儿园前到大学的内容塞进了几百页——就像，可能是一百——不，200，150页。[笑声] 让我看看。[笑声]
It takes real conviction to use the book. It goes from basically pre-kindergarten to college inside of a few hundred-- like, maybe a hundred-- no, 200, 150 pages. Let's see. [LAUGHS] Let me look at it.
这不是你随手一拿就能突然掌握的东西。
It is not something that you just pick up, and all of a sudden you have mastery.
不。它需要努力。尽管如此，《蓝皮拼写书》还是变得非常重要。正是这个物体，布克·T·华盛顿和W·E·B·杜波依斯对他们来说，《蓝皮拼写书》都很重要。《蓝皮拼写书》里有一些极其美国化的东西。它不仅成为学习阅读的一种方式，实际上，还成为进入他们以前从未考虑过的各种领域的工具。
No. It requires work. And despite that fact, his Blue-Back Speller becomes something that is important. This same object, it's Booker T. Washington and WEB Du Bois for whom the Blue-Back Speller matters. There's something quintessentially American about the Blue-Back Speller. It becomes not only a way to learn to read, but actually, a tool for entry into all kinds of arenas where they had not been contemplated.
《蓝皮拼写书》之所以成为今天的样子，并非因为诺亚·韦伯斯特的天才。它之所以成为今天的样子，是因为那些阅读它的人，是他们让它变得有意义。
The Blue-Back Speller wasn't what it was because of the genius of Noah Webster. It became what it became because of the people who read it, who made something of it.
罗曼·马斯。这个故事的一个版本最初在他新节目《100个对象讲述美国史》中播出。它最初由普里西拉·阿拉比制作，经BBC工作室制作有限公司、《99%隐形》和Sirius XM许可播出。你可以在任何获取播客的地方找到《99%隐形》里的这个系列。伊曼妮·佩里在她的新书《Black in Blues》中讲述了《蓝皮拼写书》的故事。
Roman Mars. A version of this story originally aired on his new show, A History of the United States in 100 Objects. It was originally produced by Priscilla Alabi and aired courtesy of BBC Studios Productions Limited, 99% Invisible, and Sirius XM. You can find the series in the 99% Invisible feed wherever you get your podcasts. Imani Perry tells the story of the Blue-Back Speller in her new book, Black in Blues.
这就带我们到了第五幕。第五幕，何塞，你能看见吗？所以，这个国家确实宣称发明了很多东西的领域之一就是音乐。有爵士乐，有R&B，有摇滚，有乡村，有嘻哈，全都是在这里创作然后出口到世界各地的。但我们确实有一些音乐传统是非常具体的，而且几乎一直留在这个国家。我们的制作人之一，伊曼纽尔·佐齐，有一个关于这样一个传统的故事。
Which brings us to Act 5. Act Five, Jose, Can You See? So one of the areas where this country can really claim to have invented a lot of things is music. There's jazz, there's R&B, there's rock, there's country, there's hip-hop, all created here and then exported around the world. But we do have some musical traditions that are very specific to this country and pretty much have stayed in this country. One of our producers, Emmanuel Dzotsi, has a story about one like that.
所以当我还是个孩子第一次搬到美国，在我成为公民的几年前，我记得注意到了这一个非常独特的事情，那就是每当我看到有人唱国歌时，他们总会加入自己的小花招。而且他们总是会在同一个地方这样做。
So when I first moved to the US as a kid, years before I became a citizen, I remember noticing this one very distinct thing, which is that every time I saw someone sing the national anthem, they put their own little twist on it. And they always seemed to do it in this one spot.
[惠特尼·休斯顿演唱的《星条旗永不落》] 自由之土上
["THE STAR-SPANGLED BANNER" BY WHITNEY HOUSTON] O'er the land of the free
这与歌手的流派无关。
It doesn't matter the genre of the singer is from.
[拉斯卡尔·弗拉茨演唱的《星条旗永不落》] 自由之土上
["THE STAR-SPANGLED BANNER" BY RASCAL FLATTS] O'er the land of the free
而且就算他们很平稳地唱完歌曲的其他部分也无关紧要。人们会唱到歌的最后部分并做一些完全不同的事情。有时他们会即兴哼唱（scat）或加入自己的歌词。
And it doesn't matter if they sing the rest of the song fairly straight. People will get to that last part of the song and do something completely different. Sometimes they scat or add their own words.
[史蒂夫·泰勒演唱的《星条旗永不落》] 自由之土上
["THE STAR-SPANGLED BANNER" BY STEVE TYLER] O'er the land of the free
我要带你去那里
I'm gonna take you there
他们会模仿玛丽亚·凯莉，因为，嗯，他们就是玛丽亚·凯莉。
They pull a Mariah Carey because, well, they are Mariah Carey.
[玛丽亚·凯莉演唱的《星条旗永不落》] 自由之土上
["THE STAR-SPANGLED BANNER" BY MARIAH CAREY] O'er the land of the free
这种情况发生得如此频繁，我想大多数美国人已经把它当作一个事实接受了。但这在其他国家根本不会发生。比如，如果你看看我出生的英国，那首国歌——
This happens so often, I think most Americans have sort of accepted it as a fact. But this sort of thing just doesn't go down like that in other countries. Like, if you take the UK, where I was born, that national anthem--
[《天佑吾王》] 上帝保佑我们仁慈的国王
["GOD SAVE THE KING"] God save our gracious king
我根本不知道我从哪里开始加入我自己的演绎。即兴发挥并不是英国人会对《天佑吾王》做的事情，对吧？就像你只是祝愿查尔斯国王生活幸福、胜利，然后就继续前进。但当我告诉我在《美国生活》的一些同事这件事时，他们感到不可思议。就像，肯定有其他国家在国歌结尾玩花样。伙计，这是歌的结尾。你还能干什么？
I have no earthly idea where I would even begin to put my own spin on it. The ad-libbing thing is not really something Brits do to "God Save the King," right? Like, you just kind of wish King Charles a happy, victorious life, and you keep it pushing. But when I told some of my coworkers at This American Life about this, they were incredulous. Like, surely, other countries play around with the end of their national anthems. It's the end of a song, dude. Like, what else are you going to do?
我听了所有这些，我个人很介意。所以我决心证明他们错了。我就此采访了五位在斯坦福大学、伯克利大学、北卡罗来纳大学等地的音乐学家。他们都同意我的看法。美国歌手在国歌结尾做的事情确实在其他国家很少见。这有很多原因。比如，弗朗西斯·斯科特·基，他写了《星条旗永不落》的歌词，特意选择了一种为炫技而设计的旋律。这与其他通常是进行曲或圣歌的国歌截然不同。
I heard all that, and I took it personally. So I set out to prove them wrong. I spoke to five musicologists about this at places like Stanford, Berkeley, UNC. And they all agreed with me. What American singers do at the end of a national anthem is something you really don't see much in other countries. And there are a bunch of reasons for that. Like, for one, Francis Scott Key, who wrote the lyrics to "The Star-Spangled Banner," specifically chose a melody that's designed for showing off. This is very different from other national anthems, which are often marches or hymns.
斯科特·基选择的曲调来自英国的一个音乐家俱乐部，基本上相当于你在才艺表演中使用那种用来展示你令人难以置信的音域和嗓音的歌曲。事实上，这就是为什么大多数人很难唱这首歌的原因。原曲有一种“你没法跟我们一起唱”的能量。
The tune Scott Key picked came from a musician's club in England and was basically the equivalent of one of those songs you use at a talent show to show your incredible range and voice. In fact, that's why the song is so hard for most of us to sing. The original tune has this kind of "you can't sing with us" energy.
[《安那克里翁之歌》] 此外，我会像我一样指导你，将维纳斯的桃金娘与巴克斯的藤蔓缠绕在一起
["THE ANACREONTIC SONG"] And besides, I'll instruct you, like me, to entwine the myrtle of Venus with a Bacchus's vine
其他国家不像我们这样即兴创作国歌的另一个原因是——他们没有我们那种即兴音乐的传统。比如，我们有爵士乐、布鲁斯、福音音乐、黑人音乐，其中内置了你不需要总是按照乐谱唱的规则。那里有，你知道，自由什么的，个性。艾灵顿公爵在20世纪40年代做过自己的版本。刚搬到美国的伊戈尔·斯特拉文斯基也做过一个。然而，第一个主要录制出来的歌手在体育赛事中站起来并决定他们要定制《星条旗永不落》并以自己的方式演唱是相对近期的。共识都指向1968年的一次特定表演。
The other reason other countries don't improvise the way we do on their anthem is-- they don't have our tradition of improvised music. Like, we have jazz, blues, gospel, Black music, where it's built in that you don't always do what's on the page. There's, you know, freedom or whatever, individuality. Duke Ellington did his own version in the 1940s. A newly moved to the US Igor Stravinsky did one too. And yet, the first major recorded instance a vocalist got up at a sporting event and decided they were going to customize "The Star-Spangled Banner" and sing it their own way is relatively recent. The consensus all points to one particular performance of the anthem in 1968.
那么，女士们先生们，请注意。请起立并加入我们的国歌演唱。
Now, ladies and gentlemen, your attention, please. Please rise and join in the singing of our national anthem.
那是世界大赛的第5场。而演唱者何塞·费利西亚诺是一位大明星。他翻唱的《点燃我》（Light My Fire）那一年发行。何塞当晚被选中演唱国歌，特别是因为他的身份，一位能提供不同东西的年轻波多黎各民谣歌手。费利西亚诺不仅改变了那首歌的一行。他的版本是对整首歌的重新构思。他几乎像是试图摆脱这首歌的宏伟，转而做相反的事情，使其变得亲密。
It was game 5 of a World Series. And the guy who sang, Jose Feliciano, was a big star. His cover of "Light My Fire" came out that year. And Jose was chosen to do the national anthem that night specifically because of who he was, a young Puerto Rican folk singer who could offer something different. Feliciano doesn't just alter that one line of the song. His version is a whole rethinking of it. It's almost like he's trying to do away with the grandeur of the song and do the opposite, make it intimate.
[何塞·费利西亚诺演唱的《星条旗永不落》] 宽阔的条纹和明亮的星星
["THE STAR-SPANGLED BANNER" BY JOSE FELICIANO] Whose broad stripes and bright stars
历经危险的战斗
Through the perilous fight
在我们注视的壁垒之上
O'er the ramparts we watched
费利西亚诺做的录音版本非常成功。他用它作为演唱会的开场曲。一年后，吉米·亨德里克斯在伍德斯托克音乐节上走得更远。
A recording Feliciano did of his version was super successful. He opened his concerts with it. And then, a year later, Jimi Hendrix goes even further at Woodstock.
[吉米·亨德里克斯演唱的《星条旗永不落》]
["THE STAR-SPANGLED BANNER" BY JIMI HENDRIX]
一大批人进行着这些大动作。马文·盖伊1983年在NBA全明星赛上的版本，听起来应该附带一张免费的水床。
And a whole raft of people take these big swings. There's Marvin Gaye's 1983 version at the NBA All-Star Game, which sounds like it should come with a free waterbed.
[马文·盖伊演唱的《星条旗永不落》] 宽阔的条纹和明亮的星星
["THE STAR-SPANGLED BANNER" BY MARVIN GAYE] Whose broad stripes and bright stars
历经危险的战斗
Through the perilous fight
每个人现在演唱方式的灵感，出现在1991年，惠特尼·休斯顿在超级碗上的演唱。她放慢了歌曲速度，将其从3/4拍改为4/4拍，这给了她更多空间。她基本上是直着唱的，直到结尾和最后一行。
The inspiration for how everybody sings it now, that arrives in 1991, Whitney Houston at the Super Bowl. She slows the song down, changes it from 3/4 time to 4/4 time, which gives her more space. And she sings it mostly straight, until the end and that last line.
[惠特尼·休斯顿演唱的《星条旗永不落》] 自由之土上
["THE STAR-SPANGLED BANNER" BY WHITNEY HOUSTON] O'er the land of the free
勇士之乡
And the home of the brave
天哪，我怀念惠特尼·休斯顿。但没错，这就是我们如何走到今天的：一种仪式，作为一名歌手，无论你的种族、音乐流派是什么，你打卡上班，做你被雇佣的工作，把歌照原本写的那样唱完，然后在结尾留两个乐句展示真正的个性。现在，我只想给你们放最后一个版本，因为这个周末，这个国家250周年纪念日，这可能是它唯一合适的场景之一了。
God, I miss Whitney Houston. But yeah, that's how we get to today, a ritual where you, as a vocalist, no matter what your race, what your genre of music, you clock in, do the job you were hired for, sing the song through like they wrote it, and you get two phrases at the end for some real personality. Now, I just want to play you one last version because this weekend, the 250th anniversary of this country, it's probably one of the only appropriate settings for it.
这一个是直截了当的，“巴顿将军在国旗前，这些颜色永不褪色，如果你不是第一，你就是最后，你只能从我冰冷的死尸手中夺走这首国歌”版《星条旗永不落》，这是我听过的。因为场合，我想，需要它。那是1986年自由女神像100周年诞辰。演唱者是桑迪·帕蒂。
This one is the most on the nose, "General Patton in front of the American flag, these colors don't run, if you ain't first, you're last, you can take this anthem from me out of my cold, dead fingers" rendition of "The Star-Spangled Banner" I have yet heard. Because the occasion, I guess, called for it. It was the 100th birthday of the Statue of Liberty, 1986. And the singer was Sandi Patty.
[桑迪·帕蒂演唱的《星条旗永不落》] 我们注视着星星
["THE STAR-SPANGLED BANNER" BY SANDI PATTY] We look to the stars
国歌通常持续两分钟左右。但桑迪，她让它持续了近六分钟。她增加了所有为这个场合写的额外歌词。而且每次你以为这首歌要结束了，还有更多。我在高中音乐理论课上学到了这个版本，因为我们的老师把它用作转调的最伟大例子。我们离碧昂丝的《Love on Top》还有六个月。但无论如何，桑迪·帕蒂，她把它唱得越来越高。
The national anthem normally runs about two minutes. But Sandi, she makes it last for almost six. She adds all these extra verses that were written for the occasion. And every time you think the song's about to end, there is more. I learnt about this version in high school in a music theory class because our teacher used it as the greatest example of key changes. We were still six months away from Beyoncé's "Love on Top." But anyways, Sandi Patty, she takes it higher and higher.
(歌唱) 美国！
(SINGING) America!
再次。
Again.
(歌唱) 美国！
(SINGING) America!
再来一次。
And again.
(歌唱) 美国！
(SINGING) America!
再来一次。
And again.
(歌唱) 美国！
(SINGING) America!
我的家！
My home!
美国！
America!
这完全荒谬，但又，某种程度上不可思议。
It is totally ridiculous, and yet, kind of incredible.
伊曼纽尔·佐齐。
Emmanuel Dzotsi.
好吧，今天的节目由伊曼纽尔·佐齐、莫莉·马塞洛和我制作。制作今天节目的人包括菲亚·本宁、达娜·奇维斯、卡西·豪利、阿德里安·莉莉、塞斯·林德、米基·米克、斯托·尼尔森、罗宾·里德、玛丽莎·罗伯逊·泰克斯特、瑞安·鲁梅里、阿丽莎·希普和克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉。我们的执行编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的高级编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆。今天特别感谢肖恩·柯林斯、安妮格雷特·福斯特、斯蒂芬·辛顿、内特·斯隆、尼古拉斯·马修、马克·克拉格、杰伊·艾利森、尼尔·德拉明、赛奇·米勒、安吉丽卡·巴斯蒂安、塞拉·克兰·默多克、阿什利·C·福特、安妮·布朗、查理·拉宁、邦妮·巴斯蒂安、劳拉·安·约翰逊、斯科特·塔克、睡熊沙丘之友、密歇根公共广播电台、萨尔·卢塞罗和克洛蒂尔德·约翰逊-比尔。
Well, the program was produced today by Emmanuel Dzotsi, Molly Marcello, and me. The people who put together today's show include Phia Bennin, Dana Chivvis, Cassie Howley, Adriene Lilly, Seth Lind, Miki Meek, Stowe Nelson, Robin Reid, Marisa Robertson Textor, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, and Christopher Swetala. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Special thanks today to Sean Collins, Annegret Fauster, Stephen Hinton, Nate Sloan, Nicholas Mathew, Mark Clague, Jay Allison, Neil Drumming, Saige Miller, Angelica Bastien, Sierra Crane Murdoch, Ashley C. Ford, Annie Brown, Charlie Lannin, Bonnie Bastian, Laura Ann Johnson, Scott Tucker, Friends of Sleeping Bear Dunes, Michigan Public, Sal Lucero, and Clotilde Johnson-Beale.
还要感谢今天的《美国生活》合伙人乔纳森·泰勒和贝基·利布曼。我说的这些“生活合伙人”是谁？他们是已经注册并支付了一点钱来帮助我们做一件非常基本的事情的人，那就是继续制作我们的节目。如果你支持这个目标，我希望你能考虑加入他们。加入我们吧。作为感谢，你会得到各种好处——最显著的，我想，就是节目继续存在。但我们也在尝试各种东西。我已经写了两周的每周通讯了。让我们看看能持续多久。去 thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners。那个链接也在节目说明中。
Thanks also today to This American Life Partners Jonathan Teller and Becky Liebman. Who are these Life Partners I speak of? They are people who have signed up to pay a little bit of money to help us do something very basic, which is to continue making our show. If that is a goal you support, I hope you'll consider joining them. Join us. You get all kinds of perks as a thanks-- most notably, I think, just the show continuing to exist. But also, we've been experimenting with all sorts of stuff. I've been writing a weekly newsletter for two weeks now. We'll see how long it goes. Go to thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners. That link is also in the show notes.
《美国生活》由公共广播交换台PRX提供给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。最近，他了解了什么是“皮肤干灰”（ashy）。我不知道。真尴尬。他不停地走到陌生人面前问——
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. Recently, he has learned what being ashy is. And I don't know. It's embarrassing. He keeps going up to strangers and asking--
我能看看你的膝盖吗？
Can I see your knees?
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是 Ira Glass，下周将带来更多《美国生活》的故事。